من ميونخ ينضم الينا عيسى طيب عيسى الى
جانب طبعا القضيه الاوكرانيه ما ابرز
الملفات المطروحه في هذه القمه
طبعا العين على اوكرانيا وروسيا والصين
هذه هي المنطلقات الثلاثه لمؤتمر
والاحتفاء بالمعارضه الايرانيه واقصاء
موسكو والروس من المؤتمر بحسب تعبير رئيس
المؤتمر الذي قال بان بوتين انقطع علاقته
مع الحضاره لكن واكد مره اخرى جلال بانها
اليوم ايضا بدات اجتماعات مجموعه السبع
على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه ايضا بما حسب ما
قالت لنا مصادر داخل المؤتمر من خلال بان
محادثات جاريه الان بين الدبلوماسيين
الصينيين واليابانيين وبان هناك احتمال
كبير ان يعقد اجتماع بين وزير خارجيه
الصين
رئيس مجلس الشونه الخارجيه بالحزب الشيوعي
الصيني بين قوسين وزير الخريج الصين وبين
نظيره وزير الخارجيه الياباني وهي محاوله
فيما يبدو انها لاعاده العلاقات مره اخرى
بعد التازم الذي اصابها الامر الاخر وهي
الصفات التي تم تسريبها من خطاب الامين
العام لحلف الناتو والذي يتضمن كما تقول
هنا مصادرنا بانه يدعو الغرب يدعو شركائه
الغربيين الى الاستفاده من درس غزو روسي
لاوكرانيا في التعامل مع الصين وبانهم هذه
الدول دول حلف الناتو الغربيه يجب ان لا
تكرر نفس الخطا في التعامل مع الصين الامر
الثاني وهو ما كشفت عنه ايضا وكاله الاباء
الفرنسيه بان الامين العاميه حوث
المشاركين على تسريع عمليه دعم اوكرانيا
من اجل انتصارها على روسيا لان وجود
اوكرانيا دوله مستقله اوروبيه في القاره
الاوروبيه هو اكبر ضمان لوقف زحف الروس
نحوها الامر الاخر وهو مواصله الخطاب
الامريكي الوفد الامريكي اليوم سيتصدر هذه
الجلسه كما لاريس نائبه الرئيس الامريكي
انتوني بريكن ستكون ايضا هناك مباحثات حول
ملف الصين خصوصا ان هناك حديث هنا في
اروقه على العقد اجتماع بين وزير خارجيه
الصين ونظيرها الامريكي واذا حدثت ستكون
اول لقاء بعد حادثه وازمه المنطاد الامر
الاخر وهي وهي مجموعه اوكرانيا نتحدث الان
عما تم الاتفاق عليه على قلب بين برلين
وباريس امس الان الحديث ان هذا الامر
الاتفاق هو الدعم المستدام لاوكرانيا
والنوع وايضا ما اضاف اليه اليوم بحسب
المقتطفات المسربه من خطاب الامينه العام
لحلف وهو ايضا ان يتم الاتفاق من خلال
اللجان تشكل هنا لجان مبنيه عسكريه نتحدث
وربما ستكون قمه او صيغه رامشتاين حاضره
لان كل الاعضاء المشاركين في قمه او في
مجموعه ايضا يجتمعون هنا ويبدو ان الملف
اوكرانيا سيكون الملف الطاغي الى اخر لحظه
من ساعات هذا المؤتمر شكرا لك عيسى في
ميونخ